glory oh my god alright so I just want
to say all of you just a big thanks to
their three teachers that are taking
this on board I mean it's pretty special
for us to have this so big clap for mr.
woo mr. Fech offer mr. Sloane thank you
thank you
when you're ready mr. Sloane
you say that you wanna fail we're
shifting again don't you dare pretend
you don't like it here but holy smokes
we've done it again
we gotta get on the highway I'm running
out of breath my essence and just
watching and desecration is let you play
here with Holly smokes went down it
again we gotta get down get down with a
shine rolling with a jazz
but Jalisco straight down it again we
gotta get down get down with the shine
rolling with a Josh
oh yeah
can't down with a Sun way rolling with a
jazz can't tell with a son rolling with
a Josh
thank you ah good work gentlemen up
there fantastic effort he's so
embarrassed but he rocked it well done
to the teachers and the kids in that one
who ever thought mr. Faircloth making
science cool
sorry miss